this is what turkeys so-called safe zone
in northern Syria really looks like
[Applause]
we're in the ethnically Kurdish village
of saram sir and this is the welcome for
the Turkish and Russian military Patrol
[Music]
the villagers here see them as invaders
and this they feel is the only way they
can defend their land watch here is one
young man climbs onto the Turkish truck
he jumps off and falls under the back
wheel teargas is fired into the village
as the vehicles push over the rocks laid
out to slow them down a close range
its effect is temporary back up the road
they struggle to get the young man who
was run over into a vehicle Sark warn
Bank in alley 26 was taken to hospital
but he later died it is such a clear
demonstration of just how quickly things
could deteriorate or imagine what the
reaction of these villagers will be like
the next time the soldiers passed
through unbusy the area public and
Canada the matter with it cannot ask any
other God with their marijuana prabhu
knocking the irony of all this is that
until now Syria's long convoluted war
hadn't reached these Kurdish villages
but the month-long Turkish incursion is
now having the impact many feared
following the convoy we saw the same in
every village and between them
locals in pursuit the objective for
Turkey here is to make their presence
felt across a wide strip of Kurdish land
along the border because the same
Kurdish militia who were key in the u.s.
coalition fight against Isis are in
Turkey's eyes terrorists themselves so
they've gone now back across the Turkish
border they were only on the ground for
about an hour or so on the face of it
it's all part of a Turkish and Russian
effort to create a safe zone right
across this border but even according to
the top American diplomat here what this
actually represents is the beginning of
a quiet and systematic ethnic cleansing
of the area an effort to push these
Kurdish people out of their homes not
far away we came across an American
military convoy still here despite
Donald Trump's talk of them leaving but
their orders now are to protect the oil
not the Kurds Mark Stone Sky News in
Syria